dieses ding ist mittlerweile echt
richtig verstaubt also nicht jetzt dass
sie hier nur eine ecke liegt die wird
natürlich bei mir gepflegt wie sonst was
aber irgendwie war da gerade richtig
viel staub an einer einzelnen stelle
aber wir sind hier nicht beim ukulelen
unterricht mal abgesehen davon dass ich
gar nicht kollege spielen kann sondern
wir sind hier bei den kräftigen und wir
fangen direkt mit an mit köpfen
lennart schreibt mir hier eine kräftige
dx gleich holz gleisen gleichwohl und
dann seht ihr auch jetzt mal das
crafting rezept einigen ländern und zwar
der unten unter noch geschrieben das
soll so eine art türsteher sein ich hab
das brav da mal aufgeschrieben ist quasi
sonnentau aus holz dann da oben ein
eisen und links an also und rechts an
eisen und in die restlichen felder kommt
ball und dann bekommt man diese
holzstatue und zwar würde ich einfach
sagen also eher dazu keine erklärung
abgegeben er meinte einfach so was wie
nylon golem nur leichter zu holen
ich würde sagen auch so ähnlich wie ein
bruder allerdings sollte er wirklich dem
namen treu bleiben und zwar türsteher
dass man den quasi sich wieso einrüstung
ständer vor die tür stellen kann
und der hält die tür quasi wenn holz für
ist von zombies ab und so also quasi
eine zombie blockade der greift dann
halt allem ob sunny im umkreis von zwei
blöcken sind und so kann man sich vor
die tür stellen der haut allem ochs weg
hat keine lebens rad oder so sondern
einfach nur also nicht dass der sterben
kann oder so sondern einfach dass der
halt quasi sehr starkes und alle mops
abwertung so und das ist auch schon
crafting idee nummer eins so bevor wir
jetzt hier zu zwei kommen dir jetzt
schon eingeblendet seht ihr eine
kräftige idee hat wo ihr denkt wow das
ist doch ganz schillig das muss jetzt
nicht unbedingt in vanilla minecraft
hinzugefügt werden demnächst aber das
wäre eventuell mal ganz cool auch für
meinen c19 c waren letztes fußball
zocken und da habe ich mir meinen zeh so
um so einen bluterguss kenne das
mindeste bluterguss habt dem c und der
muss dann raus wachsen und ja ich weiss
es ekelig jedenfalls tut höllisch weh
ich bin gegen meine erste zeit im
schneidersitz ein bisschen auf meinem
als auch komplett egal wenn ihr
jedenfalls irgendeine idee habt und ihr
denkt euch hat denn das in minecraft
sein würde müsste es die und die
kräftigen form haben dann in die
kommentare schreiben so wie ihr das hier
auch immer eingeblendet sehen und jetzt
mal weil wir hier weiter hier mit dem
crafting nummer zwei und zwar schreibt
die daniel p ich bin für eine insekten
farm in minecraft was kann sie
unterschiedlich zum beispiel bienen
geben die neben könig okay ich glaube
sie meint nicht könig sondern honig und
zwei bühnen geben honig und den honig
kann man dann weiterverkauft mit einem
milch einmal der filtern 35 hunger aus
dann kann man auch eine farm machen und
regen würden und dann schmeißt man die
blätter beispielsweise da rein und da
bekommt man erde also sich hat sich das
schon sehr viele gedanken gemacht habe
es allerdings mal nur eine kräftige
drangenommen weil es kräfte die nummer
zwei da kann ich jetzt ein fünf kräftige
den randen oder so und zwar sieht er es
gab schon eingeblendet das ist nämlich
einfach ein milchglas da unten und
darüber würde ich dann einfach irgendwo
nicht packen oder so den honig bekommt
man dann quasi von irgendwelchen bienen
oder pflanzen oder westlich und damit
kann man sich dann erst mal überhaupt
eine biene kräften wenn die dennoch
nicht in minecraft wirklich
implementiert wurde kann man die quasi
sodann sich einfach mal holen und die
biene von der biene kann man sich dann
wiederum wiederholen also in etwa wie
man kriegt ja kakaobohnen einfach so im
wald muss man sich dann so im dschungel
mitnehmen aber die kann man auch zu
hause an pflanzen dann hat man da quasi
vielmehr kakaobohnen also ich weiß nicht
ich das sagen soll man kann quasi erst
den honig mitnehmen einfach aus der
bildband mit den honig kann man sich
dann bienen kräften und mit den bienen
kann man sich dann wiederum noch mehr
honig von den hohlen ich hoffe ich hab
das jetzt richtig erklärt und nicht wie
so ein total trendy aber ich hoffe mal
ihr wisst was ich meine da gibt es auf
jeden fall immens die möglichkeit es
gibt auch schon viele die mods also
bienen modifikationen und so die in
minecraft vorhanden sind aber ihr wisst
es freunde sage ich immer wieder ich bin
jemand der ist dafür es müssen mehr
möbel in minecraft und mehr tiere und es
muss alles ein bisschen lebendiger sein
und da wird das auf jeden fall dazu
passen
crafting idee nummer drei wurde mir
zusammen von kuba ist play und zwar ich
bin für einen hunde schrägstrich
katzenkorb crafting sehen wir jetzt
gleich mal eingeblendet und zwar erstmal
man kann hundert schrägstrich katzen
dahin befehligen
der hund trägt die katze wird dort drin
geheilt dann sehen wir jetzt mal das
crafting rezept wie er
geschrieben hat und zwar einfach ein
boot in minecraft machen und dann kann
man da eingeschlossen davon noch einen
winter eine tolle farbe hinlegen und
zwar habe ich das beispielsweise mal
orange hingelegt und dann seht ihr schon
habe ich dass da so ein bisschen orange
gemacht jedenfalls haben wir dann quasi
hier in dem fall seien hundekorb oder
der hund drin sitzt das heißt wenn man
den hund hat der einem selbst gehört als
mit armband so weiter also halsband und
so weiter und so fort kann man dem
einfach rechts klicken und dann quasi
über diesen hundekorb laufen lassen dann
setzte sich automatisch in rom kommt
rein
oder man schiebt ihn halt wenn der hund
sitzt in den hundekorb rein und dann
heilt er sich dort auf man muss ihm
nicht in fleisch geben damit sein
schwanz quasi wieder hochgeht okay das
mit schwanz hochgehen hört sich jetzt
vielleicht ein bisschen zweideutig an
aber ich denke ihr wisst was ich meine
man muss ja in minecraft wenn der hund
so total am sterben gerade ist und der
brauch unbedingt was zu es muss man eben
ja so ein bisschen fleisch geben und so
damit der schwanz ein bisschen höher
geht das zeigt er quasi den hunger stand
von dem hund beziehungsweise den
gesundheitsstand und das wird dann quasi
sonne quasi healing sondern quasi quasi
quasi wird halt deine kleine hier liegen
stationen für den hunden und das
crafting die nummer drei und bekommen
jetzt schon zu kräftigen idee nummer
shuffle waffel schreibt eine heizung
wäre cool man kann damit zum beispiel
wasser gefrieren
im umkreis von xy blöcken das wetter
etwas grafing rezept ein hier der
scharfe waffe da das zum ersten mal kann
er mit wasser gefrieren mit einer
heizung dann kommt aber der rap chain
gamer an mit einer heizung wasser
gefrieren
astori was laura ich mit der heizung
sollte man eis schmelzen können und
kaktus umkreis wachsen von der wärme
auch so was gemeint und dann sehen wir
jetzt auch mal das crafting rezept
eingeblendet oben links ein kompass dann
alles andere voll mit eisenwaren außer
die untere zeile und in die untere zeile
kommen zwei stärker in die mitte wird
einfach frei gelassen
dann bekommen wir dieses heizungs
ähnliche gebilde und zwar dachte ich
erst so damit eis gefrieren lassen es
schmelzen lassen ist doch total unnötig
allerdings ist allerdings dass mit der
wärme für unter anderem kakteen
zuckerrohr
karotten kartoffeln den ganzen samen und
zwar alles weh das ist es eine gute idee
ich hoffe er hat verstanden was ihr
sagen wollte als man kräfte sich quasi
diese heizung das ist dann quasi so eine
erweiterung für die farm die man hat
weil dann dadurch alles durch die wärme
besser wächst also wie in seinem
gewächshaus dass man da so ein bisschen
für den luftfeuchtigkeit sorgt und so
was alles ich mache schon weiter mit
kräftig die nummer fünf rocky schreibt
ein poker ball gleich als er gleich rats
und vegleich werfer dann habe das
crafting rezept mit dem pokal kann man
tiere und mops einsammeln und mitnehmen
keine and mops und dann schreibt
allerdings untendrunter der depot ich
würd's nicht nennen weil das duft ist
wenn man was aus einem anderen spiel
nimmt ich würde eine art cage machen mit
folgendem crafting rezept allerdings
habe ich von dem depot nur die idee
übernommen er von dem rookie die idee
und die fürs rafting rezept ein bisschen
und von dem depot so ein bisschen auch
noch was anderes also ich zeige euch
erstmal jetzt ist rafting rezept was ich
mir gedacht habe und zwar oben drein
redstone dann kohle kohle in die mitte
einen button und darunter drei eisen das
ist für mich so sieht er einen pokal aus
anstatt irgendwie somit mit red storm um
die ecke und dann eisen in der ecke und
dann in die mitte noch was anderes oder
diese skating man muss es allerdings
nicht pokal nennen also die leute da
kamen auf die idee ich würde allerdings
so machen weil so ist es schon in
irgendeiner mod vorhanden die ich auch
damals mal vorgestellt hatte ich meine
das war die pokemons modification von
minecraft oder irgendwie so da wurde das
ganze jedenfalls auch so gekracht und
damit kann man quasi einfach seine tiere
mitnehmen also man muss dann nicht immer
mit seinen weißen stock rumlaufen weizen
stock sondern man kann quasi einfach bei
einem umzug seine ganzen tieren
verschiedene bälle packen man könnte
dann beispielsweise noch den pokal mit
wolle oder mit einem farbstoff ins
inventar packen da bekommt man den
verschiedenen farben und dann wird auch
oben angezeigt ja hier ist eine kuh drin
und hier ist ein mythos drin
unser ganzer scheiß also kannst alles
reinpacken von umzug sehr geil muss man
sich mit den tieren 1000 blöcke laufen
oder irgendwie so natürlich freunde
jetzt kommen wir die händler um die ecke
gekrochen
hey da sollte es nicht geben das ist gar
nicht mein kraft aber freunde essen
crafting ideen und nicht crafting
vorschläge für minecraft sondern einfach
nur ideen auf was man kommen könnte
idee ist alles alles ist die idee wenn
ihr eine idee habt schreibt unten
kommentare ich würde mich freuen wenn er
ganz viele kräftige wieder ankommen
würden und dann kommt in der woche oder
so mal wieder eine neue folge von ich
würde mich auch unter über einen daumen
und dann sehen wir uns bestimmt bei
irgendwann wieder chips